la población indígena de Perú pide ser
escuchada a medida que se intensifican
las protestas en el país andino llegan a
la capital grupos de comunidades
indígenas de los pueblos aymaras
quechuas huaris entre otros provenientes
principalmente del sur y el Oriente del
país denunciando olvido estatal
las provincias la gente provincial a
quien humillan todo el tiempo la gente
de Lima los grandes por eso nos
levantamos no es por gusto el congreso
es un invento europeo que en el Perú hoy
es obsoleto
más de la mitad de los 33 millones de
peruanos se consideran mestizos y una
cuarta parte indígena pero una encuesta
del Ministerio de cultura asegura que
más del 81% de los peruanos está de
acuerdo en que existe discriminación
indígena un pueblo que usualmente Es
relacionado con el terrorismo
recientemente la Policía Nacional
aseguró encontrar infiltrados de la
organización sendero luminoso dentro de
las manifestaciones
mientras que una delegación de la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos que visitó Perú durante las
protestas aseguró que existe una fuerte
estigmatización por factores étnicos
raciales y regionales
Pedro Castillo un profesor de escuela
llegó al poder en 2021 representando a
los sectores Rurales y empobrecidos de
Perú y muchos exigen la liberación del
destituido presidente a pesar de las
promesas incumplidas y las acusaciones
de corrupción en su contra su
vicepresidenta Dina boluarte quien
asumió el cargo después de la
destitución de Castillo está lejos de
seguir la política de su predecesor que
aseguraba un cambio para los pueblos
indígenas que quieren ser incluidos en
una nación y que hoy por hoy tienen en
jaque a su gobierno